Yes, a
presentation is a
battle.
It's too unfavorable for our strategy, but since it's
started, there's no choice but to win the fight
.
Hearing Ability There
are no specific figures listed
Comparison graph with other Soi people Yes Yes Yes
It has better performance
Happy cheating It's
too easy and too simple naming
Each set art collection Acrobatics
This movement is Nessie and Kinren roll log
ha
Leader's material cargo
Esso Women are people and names are also female  It's better to
do it because it's related to erasing Terada
, so it seems that's it for this time
.
[MUSIC]
But in this ground-breaking monster,
if
ani ah ah ah
teaching specialties from radar attack
Unboxing of attack from the inside
ah ah ah
[music]
ban
I see, it's pretty interesting
but
this
Is it possible to realize it with the
budget?